une d une des cinq maps que je quitte le
plus au monde
mais franchement c'est vrai sophie
davant mecheri c'est pas la patronne
sophie pour moi c'est la taulière de la
télé ça rester la patronne ya michel
drucker et sophie davant vim
non mais et toi tu fais pas de vélo mais
si tu aimes la vie voilà à thomas sophie
et ben oui merci de m'accueillir surtout
d'être aussi sympa je suis contente de
voir en plein à son émission c'est un
carton absolu on va en parler on la voit
moi j'ai beaucoup d'amis et de fans oui
qu'ils sont fous de sophie ils sont
voilà qui son délire sur sophie quoi ils
ont vide ils sont vides à pécho sur
ambac coiffe aussi pour moitié aux mais
présentent jamais ses joies on va
s'occuper de toi que tu va repartir dit
moi j'étais pour avec la veste à mon
avis ne sera pas possible 1981-1983
première génération minitel
effectivement vous en attendez entre
5000 et 10000 non non je pense alors
jamais blanc que j'aime bien ce côté
gentleman charbon
c'est là le pantalon en velours côtelé
non non non non là bas il a juste merci
sophy ça va s'en fout on me regarde et
audi avec vous voyez un ouf
mais vous êtes une romantique ça vous
surprendront pas du tout alors mais
c'est vrai morceau qui n'est romantique
quoi temps qu'il remonte chez les
meilleurs vous vous êtes lourd mais les
mathématiques c'est plus vous aimez bien
jean-michel ou pas et bien sûr une
aventure ils sont michel plus je crois
ben oui ou non ça veut dire non donc ça
veut dire non non franchement maintenant
vous faites une émission sur les
brocantes
est ce que vous pourriez soit une
émission sur les brocantes il a raison
ouais bon écoutez elle nous dira jamais
mort parce que sophie qui est une
personne j'ai schilick public impala
n'ont pas pu dire non non non non elle
vous respecte c'est tout et peut pas
vous faire de peine tout à son honneur
bah voilà vous avez vous c'est votre
s'il a complètement mais qui n'est pas
sans raison voilà j'aime bien le côté
poivre et sel et les barbus de trois
jours ah oui et méfiez vous quand même
qu'il est pas mal donc
ça dépend pour quoi en fait c'est à dire
pour une nuit bertreau pour une vie jean
michel horn allons peut-être pas jusque
là mais on peut réfléchir aux activités
très bien mais show qu'elle allait bien
jean-michel 1 sophie avec demandé
longtemps ce one s offrir fois est-ce
que vous accepteriez un dîner avec jean
michel maire vous allez revenir n'avait
pas fait la dernière fois c'est pour moi
c'est cadeau c'est moi qui régale
choisir du
hippopotamus et pour moi c'est cadeau
alors on peut se persuader que j'ai dit
je vais pas dire non je serais quand
même s'est vendu
[Applaudissements]
merci